1378 kilometer australien mit singapore
airlines täglich im airbus a380 ab
zürich
sieben wochen bin jetzt unterwegs auf -
noch im australischen glück einen job
die 100 kilometer hinter mir und jetzt
benni verkleiden station
ich begleite begleiten so viel sie
generationen bewirtschaftet die familie
die ihr typischer stralis form mit dem
outback der form so gross wie der kanton
tessin wierichs leben auf dem land
wurden ages nachbarbetrieb kilometer
wieder was gelernt
auf ihrem land zu gold fields rinde und
zusätzlich hatten die haare halb will
die russen die probierte zusammenleben
mit hilfe zweier jährige roth sowas ist
der plan
dort würden sie ist eine staubwolke
das sind die pferde wir fahren gleich
über meinen vater zu helfen
seinem vater ja dort siehst du das licht
seines motorrads er fährt mit einigem
abstand zur erde
er treibt die pferde darüber und wir
schneiden ihnen dann den weg
[Musik]
es sind praktisch videos maximal zwei
bis drei mal im jahr zusammen
[Musik]
es ist vorstellbar so was wir gerade
jetzt jetzt klick zusammenkriegen
[Musik]
die tiere und natur bestimmen slama form
das erinnert mich an meine kindheit im
all ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
begleiten trend micros vor der harder
der grund ist dass die reinen rossstall
besitzer in paris verkauft
begleiten
letzteres ganzes jahr in kanada als
pferdeflüsterer bilder in so moment
konnte weiß haare von kohle cowboy zum
verschieben es ist noch ganz aufgedreht
und zusammenstellen
ich muss sie zuerst beruhigen ich spiele
ein wenig mit hier rum und versuche die
bindung zu ihr aufzubauen
sie muss wieder vertrauen zu legen
mit hilfe von der ausländer blacher
versuchten die schreckhaftigkeit so tut
er das ross auf den transport
vorbereiten
bedeutet für dich glück mit pferden zu
arbeiten
es ist eine leidenschaft für mich ich
reite seit ich zwei jahre alt und 10
habe ich mein erstes wildes pferd
gezählt wenn du pferden aufgewachsen
habe mit ihm viele schöne dinge erlebt
ich fühlte mich pferden immer nahe
ich liebe es mit ihm zu arbeiten und
neue ziele mit ihnen zu erreichen
es ist eine leidenschaft du darfst dich
nicht verkrampfen sei so wie du bist
dann nimmt sie dich an hast du erfahren
20 jahre lang angst du musst also
einzige vertrauen gewinnen lasse dich
kennenlernen
sie sollte ich mit beiden nüstern
riechen kann denn jedes nasenloch
verarbeitet unterschiedliche
informationen und halte sie an der
kurzen leine
da kannst du sie besser kontrollieren
vergiss nicht zu lächeln
[Musik]
wenn mittags oder brennt wir die form
nicht geschafft die db oldfield von
fleck tier die man im hochsommer das
thermometer bis auf 50 rathaus stiege
trieben der schein unterschreitens nach
der in der zange um sie vor der hitze
schützen
ich fühle mich fast wie daheim
dort fehlt sind einfach hier und
ehrliche lied sie erinnere mich an weil
es der bank führe aber die charaktere
der menschen in australien sind schon
sehr unterschiedlich wenn man euch mit
den städtern vergleich die stadt und das
outback das sind zwei völlig
unterschiedliche menschen schläge aber
steht die einander nicht wirkt die
menschen im outback sind füreinander da
wir sind wie eine große familie wenn
einer probleme hat einen alle zu hilft
städte kennen nicht einmal ihre nachbarn
die reden nicht miteinander
wir plaudern mit allen die im umkreis
von 500 kilometer von uns leben
wir helfen einander so überleben wir
hier draußen seit generationen also gute
beziehungen zu den nachbarn sind wichtig
ohne diesen zusammenhalt wäre das leben
gehabt
wirkliche haltung ich noch arbeit vor
den familien fehlt ist extrem trocken
und karg 100 kilometer staffel trotz
höherer zu sammeln
es ist ein langes langes die zu einer
instanz worden ob ich in weiblicher hand
verweisen
aber der kleine begleiter ins outback
also wir bauen wir ein gatter radio
schweißen verstrebungen für ein gatter
brauchen wir die türkei er kann nicht
schnell in die eisenwarenhandlung gehen
die ist 800 kilometer weit weg wir haben
inter muss unseren eigenen zappa
sperrmüll und altmetall den durchsuchen
wir wenn wir etwas brauchen musste zu
helfen wissen
alles wird wiederverwendet nichts wird
weggeworfen
das sind auch die wasserleitung
[Musik]
begleitend große planen kann zusammen
mit seiner frau der welt vor mobil
leider ist die je gedreht unter träume
ist somit platz juni beide seen laden
jetzt innenstadt wieder weg vor ihm
ich weiß dass ich das thema oder kleid
nicaragua
darum probiert es mit einem lockeren
spruch muss ganz schön schwierig seien
hier im outback eine frau kennenzulernen
ja du läufst nicht gerade täglich einer
über den weg erst recht keine meisten
schweizer touristinnen
die auswahl ist bescheiden
du musst einfach jede chance nutzen hast
du eine freundin in ein zurzeit bin ich
singen
natürlich wünsche dem kleinen dass er
bald weiteres neues klick findet in dem
zusammenhang werde mir giottos etr von
hold back bewusst manche ein die zwar
die große frie hält gepachtet aber sie
schwierigen partners finden mag man's
klick geschlagen
[Musik]
und so verabschiede ich mich von ahlbeck
und machen richtig großstadt mini reichs
geht wieder ins meer
und dennoch melden ich bin nun andere
seite von roten kontinent keine
abschieds von der bekannte waage
bis vor sechs gefährliche riesig
entsprachen sind die dimensionen familie
reis 12 380 kilometer in 70
[Musik]
nach über 2000 km südküste dem coto ein
unglaublicher kontrast zu der hits und
dem stopp im outback
je länger ich 100 wachsen
umso mehr von mir ruft da so strahlend
schöne große kontrast und erforschen
unendlich mit praktisch ist auch dass
ein teil von der magie vor dem land
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen schmecken zahlst in
der luft ich bin hockey der inbegriff
für meine surfer auf der perfekt weil er
ins klickrate auf jeden fall war
sorry entschuldigung kann ich etwas
fragen
du siehst wie ein profi surfer aus ich
bin aus der schweiz und stand noch nie
auf einem surfbrett
wo kann ich das lernen
ganz gleich ins wasser springen aber
einen lehrer findest du in einem das
surf shops oben in der stadt aber du
könntest das doch machen
du siehst wie ein alter hase nein ich
bin kein lehrer aber das ist schon was
macht ihr hier sind dass eine schülerin
ja das ist ein lebensretter kurs wofür
neben sie etwa für eine wettkampf
was trainieren sie gerade ausdauer auf
ihren brettern wie oft trainiert ihr
jeden abend jeden abend drei mal auch am
morgen also dann ist das wie ein klub
mit mir kaiser von rechts
also schickt er mit verschiedenen
kollegen tyler und die keine mehr sicher
wieder verwenden
hallo zusammen ich bin sven penning
ich telefoniere mit dem typen der an
surfbrett für dich hat er steht morgens
um 7 auf der matte und du wirst ja aber
die vermietung hat eigene neben du
kannst auch einen von denen man schon
okay du bist mein lehrer
komm mit
oh ja
herzlich willkommen in australien das
ist die unterschrift eines hais
[Musik]
in die
am nächsten morgen kann ich mit meinem
surflehrer daniela gemacht
[Musik]
am strand und auf dem parkplatz auf mich
die bisher von ihnen surfen
[Applaus]
ihr kennt sich ja daniel ich kann ihn
nicht finden er will mir heute surf
unterricht geben
daniel nie gehört
wenn ihr
im wallis sind superstars lehrern
australien
ja
wo lebst du da drüben ein freund hat
seine fan dort üben
ich wohne gerade bei ihm sei deswegen am
strand schlafverhalten mit verschlafenen
blick sie hofft erschien easy
besucherzahl
das ist bekannteste buch per speedboot
das sagen die kenner der server war für
stigmatisiert drogenabhängige surfer und
zechpreller warf man in denselben topf
das hat sich geändert
anwälte im anzug fahren mit ihrem
mercedes und rolls royce an den strand
um vor der arbeit surfen
früher waren die autos abgetakelt die
surfer bauten herbort selbst den
baracken am stern
und was machst du
damit es nicht zu rutschig ist
gesagt
jetzt bin hier geboren
normal und services im laden daniel
major wer beim surfen habe ich wirklich
nie finden surfer skisport sondern
erlauben es halt ich ganz unter dem
motto immer schön locker bleiben
es sieht verdammt schwierig aus eine
gute welle zu erwischen ja sie sind
klein und unregelmäßig aber wir finden
schon eine für dich okay
[Musik]
walter im richtigen moment mal bin ich
früher und sondern mal sport
[Musik]
als solist ist wasser nicht wirklich mit
einem anruf von der surfer könnte - wenn
jetzt aber sie jetzt matt ward von der
großstadt wie snacks zu melden
oder zwei drittel von der gehört 320
millionen australien haben die eine
großstadt der küste und will mehr würden
als kulturmetropole geahndet
ein künstler familie ausgesucht die
tochter olympia nelson spontan
innerschweizer landessprache wechselt
olympia ist
[Musik]
die tempi fünf jahre spielte klavier
doch dies nur mit qigong von peter roth
mit dem jugendorchester von melbourne
da werfen nur die wäsche mit noch
[Musik]
olympia hat ihre musik ist eine von der
bekanntesten fotografinnen australien
und der vater ist professor und
kunstkritiker ganz schön heiß da drin
ja es ist heiß heute haben der 40 grad
und beim spielen bewege ich die arme so
viel ich begleitet olympia durch
melbourne ihre eltern mich heimisch
glaube ich lebe gerne hier in melbourne
du bist hier aufgewachsen ja wir leben
seit jeher im gleichen haus das ist es
ist die familie zu hause
ich glaube schon amélie nelson fitzroy
ehemalige arbeiter und heutige trend
quartier war sie das haus vor xi r
greift hat in der gegend niemand
freiwillig welle wohnen
hallo schön dich kennenzulernen hallo du
kaufst gerade ja unser sohn salomon hat
sich truthahn sandwich mit spinat
gewünscht und da gehören laut rezept
karamellisierte zwiebeln rein darum
richtig bewusst dass stadt und manchem
outback ist dass beide australien sind
wenig gemeinsamkeit in der kufe lädiert
frau von robert kloos ab durch jähriger
kern hat griechische wurzler und heißt
eigentlich pohlig seele papa pedro sie
studierte und ich erspare zur krone
strom
die war schon ganz wie du bekommst
nichts das ist traditionelles
griechisches essen und das ist humor
und ihrem robert verheerend in der
kunstszene outback kennen sie im besten
fall verbuchte indes fleck in
klimatisierte auto viel ausstrahlung
sind in ihrem leben nur ein bruchteil
bei jedem kontinent also der begriff
lucky country taucht immer wieder auf
was heißt das es ist das glücklich wir
sind in jeder hinsicht reich wirklich
wir sind gesegnet bodenschätzen tollem
wetter traumstränden finnland unsere
welt ist wirklich eine glückliche
andererseits sind wir so weit weg vom
rest der welt wir leben in einem
trügerischen paradies so gesehen sind
wir das unglückliche land ein
australischer historiker hat ein buch
geschrieben es heißt die tyrannei der
abgeschiedenheit und ja wir leiden unter
dieser tyrannei der abgeschiedenheit wir
brauchen 24 stunden um nach europa zu
reisen
ein anderer ausdruck für australien
china freund mit die kunst war auf
knopfdruck
das ist zwar schön dich kennenzulernen
du bist also ich bin der clubspitze list
das ist sehr spannend für mich ich habe
noch nie gesehen wie stur das macht das
großartig
im siebdruckverfahren transport der
olympia-achte von der politischen klasse
die grünste fotografiert frau
schließlich hinein
das porträt für ihre tochter wünsche mit
einem anderen foto kombinieren wohl
nicht genug partie und so viel
hintergrund finde ich das verhältnis
stimmt nicht
entscheidend ist wie viel sehen wieder
vom portrait und wie viel vom
hintergrund es sieht irgendwie
verwirrend aus die beiden motive
verschmelzen zu stark
warum willst du das porträt auf glas
truppen
mir gefällt glas weil es ein
zerbrechliches medium ist ich wollte mir
dieser zerbrechlichkeit spielen
wir menschen sind oft zerbrechliche
wiesen im umgang mit glas muss man sehr
vorsichtig sein und ich denke mit den
menschen ist es dasselbe
abrashi sehr zerbrechlich sieht man ja
habt ihr die familie mit der gewissheit
dass sie unheilbar an krebs erkrankt ist
ich lebe einfach mein leben
klar ich mache manchmal auf und wünschte
mir ich wäre nicht so krank aber dieser
gedanke bringt dich nicht weiter du
musst dein leben leben
ich muss mich ums haus kümmern um die
familie meine arbeit als künstlerin
ich versuche die krankheit zu vergessen
so gut es geht
deine familie weiß also deine situation
spreche darüber
nein das wäre zu schwierig für sie was
soll ich ihnen sagen es ist einfach zu
schwierig ich weiß nicht wie sie damit
umgehen
es hat sich auch gar nicht so viel
verändert seit ich so krank ich habe
gehofft die kinder würden vermehrt im
haushalt helfen weil ich so krank bin
aber es hat sich nichts geändert das ist
gut
ich finde das ist sehr gut sie sehen
mich also immer noch als gesunde mutter
die für sie da ist
manchmal fühle ich mich sehr schlecht
und muss ins krankenhaus
aber die tatsache dass sie mich nicht um
sorgen ist gut sie finden ich sei gesund
genug um alles für sie zu tun
vielleicht besteht jetzt glück heute
nicht über das unglück zu reden
polen will probeaufnahmen fressen als
kunstprojekt machen
robert hat erinnerung malt und person
solomon wird modellstadt es okay für
dich wenn wir probeaufnahmen machen ich
hole nur schnell ein kostüm und das
letzte mal als du diesen umhang getragen
heißt reichte er dir bis zum knöchel
könnte dich erinnern was ist los mit dir
gesehen du bist so gewachsen
halt den totenkopf so das ist nach
wunsch so ist es gut sehr gut danke so
dumm und so bleiben perfekt was hat dich
zu diesem sujet in der kunst steht der
totenkopf häufig als symbol für die
sterblichkeit des menschen und ich denke
natürlich an meinen eigenen tod
ich habe noch nie ein foto mit einem
totenkopf gemacht darum hat mich dieses
experiment gereizt mir kommt vor dass
die police schicksal mit einem
augenzwinkern probiert bewältigen
erhöhter vor ihre fotos zeigen die
tochter olympia in male auf der
situation
die bilder sind licht mysteriös und
politisch pulli mit so langer zeit
wieder an ihrer kunststoffe
es bewegt mich mit familie mit ihrem
schicksal umgeht
es zeigt wie fragil skicross ihm egal
wofür waltrop in australien oder in der
schweiz
[Musik]
das pferd zum eine reisende
ich dachte kurz in das fremde und reise
der wieder fitte die bedrückende
geschichte wohl nirgendwo mit aber lasst
sie doch hinter mir und fahrens nannten
[Musik]
die seltsam wie sandra busch wir 2003
also von elf jahren
aber wir werden sie nicht kaputt und
somit auch die holen sich wieder in
einer baumkrone als weniger abgesetzt
[Musik]
wie snatch ziel
ich stell gärte es abgemacht mit weniger
als 100 einwohner
wenn es nach dem willen von der politik
komme hänge der ländlich villa
verhindert sei msh
die größere bekanntheit als sydney oder
melbourne erlangt morgen kann ich etwas
fragen dem dass das dann getty mal
beinahe die hauptstadt von australien
geworden wäre
soviel ich weiss ja keine ahnung du
musst den barkeeper fragen erst von hier
erlebt hier im pub muss ich fragen
hallo
morgen kann ich etwas fragen und ich
habe keine zeit wirklich nur zwei
minuten
es stimmt ist dass der getty mal beinahe
die hauptstadt von australien wurde
wie kam es dazu ich weiß es nicht ich
kenne nur die bildlegende wird im bild
trüben
das ist das foto und die bildlegende
dazu das sind die minister damals und
was machen die in wasser das wasser vom
ghetto tassen weiß nicht ich hatte
wirklich keine geschichte dazu erzählen
ok ich muss mich also an die welt
verändert
das sind minister vor der australische
provinz sie hätten in 203 entstand ort
führen gemeinsame hauptstadt sydney und
melbourne sind damals lieber alexy
minister eine standortunabhängig
zwischen den zwei großen bereich das
foto entstanden und öffentlichkeit
geschichte gaga der partie entschieden
will eine suite von riesen bahnlinie axi
und andere sich minister vorsieht neben
nachteilig fühlt will wenige kilometer
von melbourne ist am art revival
vorsieht
magic damals für es anderes macht
[Musik]
der heutige hauptstadt traf ich meiner
nächsten gesprächspartner der urs
wälterlin als korrespondent für
schweizer radio und fernsehen und
leipzigs jahr in australien
dass für dich so genannten home bei ist
die oft recht ich bin oft wo ich wohne
bei der stunde nördlich foto als sich
sehr noch und spielt sich natürlich
politik ist ein künstler wie heinz klewe
brasilia in brasilien
aber es in der burgstadt ich besitze der
schweiz kein branche maler schiffsfonds
in front das war super zum spiel
es gibt grünes land so groß ist um so
wenig aubergine politik weiß im
vergleich zum wurf aus nis outfit eher
zur schaufel als staatspolitik aber
bereich schon mit einer heimlich und
quer durch australien tourt er mit einer
politik für abgemacht war es karl ammann
zeigt guten morgen
engels wie guten morgen ich bin zwar
sehr gut wir haben es gefunden
es ist nicht so schwierig so ein
riesiges gebäude zu finden
das ist unhöflich versteht 1988 kann man
das parlament gebäude eröffnet hat ist
ihr stück gebäude opfer war sie mit
weniger als 1 million schweizer franken
kostet ich finde sieht wirklich alles
sehr teuer aus hier ja das stimmt
einige teile setzt für die regierende
liberale party im repräsentantenhaus der
ökonom hat vier sind und ist eine
baustraße dürfen wir reingehen
das ist das parlament 150 repräsentanten
die regierung setzt auf dieser seite
die opposition da drüben und die kleinen
parteien irgendwo hier und im gegensatz
zur schweiz geht es hier sehr laut zu
und her
das ist ein teil unserer kultur
wir gehen direkt miteinander um das ist
ganz typisch australisch wir sehen es in
diesem parlament die debatten sind
berühmt berüchtigt
einige finden das toll wir finden es
schlicht unanständig aber die realität
ist dass dies einfach zu unserer kultur
wird was sind die großen themen im
parlament zur zeit
es gibt verschiedene große team aber das
mit abstand wichtigste sind die
arbeitsplätze
seit die rohstoffpreise einbrechen unter
investment boom abkühlt müssen wir
schauen wie wir arbeitsplätze schaffen
können das ist eine wirklich harte
debatte
als ich mich auf diese sendung
vorbereitet lass ich viel über das lucky
country
wie sehen sie das nun gewisse leute
übersetzenden austria bekannt als das
land das schwein gehabt hat und so zu
wohlstand kann
wir hatten aber nie einfach schwein
wir hatten stets auch probleme zu
bewältigen eine große herausforderung
zur zeit ist die wirtschaftslage unsere
arbeitslosenquote
wir haben mit dem rohstoffboom einiges
unserer konkurrenzfähigkeit eingebüßt
wir müssen das glück wieder in der hand
nehmen wir nehmen die welt so wie sie
ist
wir machen unser eigenes glück indem wir
uns den realitäten anpassen und die
probleme pragmatisch anpassen
in den nächsten volk begleitet
rheine
denn traf ein schräger vogel der
ururenkel von charles nimmt nicht mit
wovon eines spektakuläres kein hirn
und lehre im quartier vor strahlen groß
und stark
durchaus drauf
[Musik]
12 1378 km australien mit globetrotter
dem spezialist für maßgeschneiderte
reise wald mit globetrotter punkt